This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，莱斯皮安，迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着这一季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。请在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会时，
they take matters into their eyes. own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I just want to
她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的报应。我们总是说要相信你的女朋友。请在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一集，当然，我们要剖析20多岁的心理。我只是想
give you guys a heads up. Today's episode will touch on themes to do with eating disorders, weight loss, body image and exercise addiction. So if that is something that you are struggling, with or you know you are particularly sensitive to, please take care. There will be some links in the description below. And honestly, feel free to skip this episode. Feel free to come back to it at a later date. It will always be here in a day, in a month, in a year when you are in a better headspace. Today, everybody, we are talking about something that almost feels too obvious to analyze. We are talking about the psychology of exercise. We all know exercise is good for us. We all know it has something to do with endorphins, something to do with a chemical reaction in our brain
提醒大家一下。今天的节目将涉及与饮食失调、减肥、身体形象和运动成瘾相关的主题。所以，如果你正在为此挣扎，或者你知道你对此特别敏感，请多加注意。下方描述中会有一些链接。老实说，请随意跳过这一集。欢迎在以后的日期再回来收听。它永远都在这里，无论是一天后、一个月后，还是一年后，当你处于更好的心理状态时。今天，各位，我们要谈论的是一个感觉太明显而无需分析的话题。我们正在谈论运动心理学。我们都知道运动对我们有好处。我们都知道它与内啡肽有关，与我们大脑中的化学反应有关，
we're not really aware of, but it is so much deeper than that. Exercise changes the literal structure of your brain. We have seen it in study after study. It makes you smarter. It makes you sharp. It greatly influences the functioning of your mind. And especially if you make exercise regular, structured, goal-centered, social, you will reduce your risk of cancer, dementia. You will reduce your risk of basically every and any disease you can think of. It also has a much darker side that many of us are all too familiar with. The use of exercise as punishment, the use of it to maintain a disordered body image, exercise addiction. We're going to talk about it all. And I promise, as boring as you may think this topic is, we're going to go deeper than
我们并没有真正意识到这一点，但它比这深刻得多。运动改变了你大脑的字面结构。我们在一个又一个的研究中看到了这一点。它让你更聪明。它让你敏锐。它极大地影响了你思维的运作。特别是如果你进行规律、结构化、以目标为中心、社交性的运动，你将降低患癌症、痴呆症的风险。你将降低患上你能想到的几乎任何疾病的风险。它也有一个我们许多人都太熟悉了的更黑暗的一面。将运动作为惩罚，利用它来维持一种失调的身体形象，运动成瘾。我们将讨论这一切。我保证，无论你认为这个话题有多无聊，我们都会比
you are probably used to talking about exercise on an emotional level, a physical level, a psychological level to kind of determine what exercises are best for us, what exercises are best for our mind, what does it do for us psychologically, how to find exercise you enjoy, and why the intensity of your exercise doesn't really matter. It's often the consistency. So there is a lot to discuss without further ado. Let's get into the psychology of exercise. We've all heard, you know, exercise makes you feel good. It makes you feel amazing. We've all probably felt the effect of a great workout. What is that feeling? Where does that actually come from? The main, like, celebrity of this topic is obviously the role of endorphins.
你可能习惯的更深入地从情感层面、身体层面、心理层面讨论运动，以确定什么样的运动最适合我们，什么样的运动最适合我们的大脑，它在心理上为我们做了什么，如何找到你喜欢的运动，以及为什么运动的强度并不重要。通常重要的是坚持。所以有很多需要讨论的内容。事不宜迟。让我们进入运动心理学。我们都听说过，你知道，运动让你感觉良好。它让你感觉棒极了。我们可能都感受过一次很棒的锻炼的效果。那种感觉是什么？它到底来自哪里？这个话题的主要“名人”显然是内啡肽的作用。
Endorphins are basically your body's endogenous opioids, meaning they are chemicals, your brain and your pituitary gland produces naturally that bind to opioid receptors in your brain, the same receptors that can be stimulated by an external source like drugs or like other substances. We hear a lot about them in reference to exercise, but they are silently involved in everything from pain management to your stress response, how your brain sees reward, basically your endorphins through all these different functions, contribute to the very human feeling of I can do hard things, whether that's in life, at work, but also when it comes to like intense physical effort. I can do hard things.
内啡肽基本上是你身体的内源性阿片类物质，这意味着它们是你大脑和脑下垂体自然产生的化学物质，它们与你大脑中的阿片受体结合，这些受体与可以通过外部来源（如药物或其他物质）刺激的受体相同。我们在提到运动时经常听到它们，但它们默默地参与了从疼痛管理到压力反应，再到大脑如何看待奖励的一切，基本上你的内啡肽通过所有这些不同的功能，促成了非常人性化的感觉——“我可以做困难的事情”，无论是在生活中、工作中，还是在进行剧烈的体力活动时。我可以做困难的事情。
What are they actually doing in your brain and your body when you exercise that makes them as powerful as they are? Essentially, as the intensity of exercise rises, your body is attempting to balance, a lot of different signals, right? Like you are deliberately putting yourself under strain, maybe under pain, under fatigue, under stress, and your conscious interpretation of that is to not do that, is to slow down.
当你运动时，它们在你的大脑和身体里到底在做什么，使它们如此强大？本质上，随着运动强度的增加，你的身体试图平衡许多不同的信号，对吧？就像你故意让自己处于压力之下，可能处于疼痛、疲劳、压力之下，而你对此的意识解读是不这样做，是慢下来。
And what endorphins do is try and work on the pain and frustration and stress part of this so that you keep going, so that you finish the workout, so that you finish the run. They make discomfort basically feel less threatening, they make it feel more tolerable so you can keep going. A big way they do that is they turn down the volume of pain signals in your body and in your mind so that you are able to continue with an activity without panicking. They are one of the reasons that effort and exercise can feel so satisfying rather than just
而内啡肽的作用是试图处理其中的疼痛、挫折和压力部分，这样你就能坚持下去，这样你就能完成锻炼，这样你就能跑完步。它们基本上让不适感感觉不那么具有威胁性，让它感觉更可忍受，这样你就可以继续前进。它们做到这一点的一个重要方式是调低你身体和大脑中疼痛信号的音量，这样你就能够在不恐慌的情况下继续进行活动。它们是努力和运动感觉如此令人满意而不是仅仅
unpleasant. It's why we get, you know, a run as high. It's why we feel so euphoric at the end of a workout, but they are not the only explanation for this feeling and for why exercise feels so emotionally rewarding. Actually, a lot of research suggests that the endorphins released into your bloodstream, like when you are working out, they actually don't cross the blood brain barrier that quickly. It seems like slightly improbable that they would be able to have that impact in such a short-term amount of time. This is the reason why scientists kind of started to look for other
令人不快的原因之一。这就是为什么我们会有，你知道，“跑步者的快感”。这就是为什么我们在锻炼结束时感到如此欣快，但它们并不是这种感觉以及为什么运动在情感上如此有回报的唯一解释。事实上，许多研究表明，当你锻炼时释放到血液中的内啡肽，实际上并没有那么快穿过血脑屏障。它们似乎不太可能在如此短的时间内产生那种影响。这就是为什么科学家开始寻找其他
explanations, like for what is really influencing our brains directly when we exercise. There is a very strong argument that has come out of this that the endocannoid system is actually what deserves a lot of the credit when it comes to the feel-good feeling of exercise. You may hear cannabinoid and think we're going to talk about marijuana. We're not actually, but they are kind of related. Endocannabinoids are molecules, your body produces that bind to the cannabinoid receptor. That is the same receptors that respond to the effects of cannabis, except cannabinoids in your body are internally produced. You don't have to smoke something or consume something to get that feeling, to get that
解释的原因，比如当我们运动时，到底是什么在直接影响我们的大脑。由此产生了一个非常有力的论点，即当谈到运动带来的那种“感觉良好”时，内源性大麻素系统实际上值得大部分功劳。你可能会听到“大麻素”并认为我们要谈论大麻。其实我们不是，但它们有点相关。内源性大麻素是你身体产生的与大麻素受体结合的分子。这与对大麻影响产生反应的受体相同，只是你体内的内源性大麻素是内部产生的。你不需要吸食什么或摄入什么来获得那种感觉，来获得那种
boost in your mood, reduction in your anxiety, sense of reward, maybe even that floaty feeling. There is so much research that shows exercise boosts endocanabinoids. But endocanabinoids also make you want to exercise too. So it kind of works both ways. Essentially, like, these chemicals are what make you feel not just good and happy, but calm. That is why you might feel lighter. calmer, floaty, after a run or after a workout. That's why you might feel relaxed. This same system also seems to influence motivation, i.e. whether or not you want to move in the first place.
情绪提升、焦虑减轻、奖励感，甚至那种飘飘然的感觉。有太多的研究表明运动会促进内源性大麻素。但内源性大麻素也会让你想运动。所以它在某种程度上是双向的。本质上，这些化学物质让你感觉不仅是好和快乐，而且是平静。这就是为什么你在跑步或锻炼后可能会感到更轻盈、更平静、飘飘然。这就是为什么你可能会感到放松。这个系统似乎也影响动力，即你是否想从一开始就动起来。
It's not just the nice feeling afterwards. There's actually something else going on. In 2019, a group of researchers from France conducted a study on a group of mice looking into this. And they basically, they asked a very relatable question. why don't some mice, why don't some people find exercise as attractive? You know, there are some mice, as there are some humans, who will happily run for miles, who will find that really rewarding, and who would, you know, prefer that over a simpler reward, like chocolate. And then there are some humans who are, and mice who are the opposite, who just really don't enjoy running, would much rather the simpler reward of a chocolate
这不仅仅是事后的那种好感觉。实际上还有别的事情在发生。2019年，来自法国的一组研究人员对一组小鼠进行了一项研究，深入探讨了这一点。他们基本上问了一个非常相关的问题：为什么有些小鼠，为什么有些人觉得运动没有那么吸引人？你知道，有些小鼠，就像有些人一样，会很高兴地跑上几英里，会觉得那非常有回报，并且会，你知道，更喜欢那样而不是像巧克力这样简单的奖励。然后有些人和小鼠则相反，他们真的不喜欢跑步，宁愿要巧克力
or of sitting down or of talking with friends. What they basically thought was that whether people are naturally drawn towards exercise comes down to these cannabinoid receptors. And so what they did is they had two groups of mice, and in one of the groups they knocked out these receptors, the receptors like what they're called CB1 receptors, they essentially didn't work. So no matter how much external amounts of this they received or internal,
或者坐着或与朋友交谈这样简单的奖励。他们基本上认为，人们是否天生被运动所吸引，归结为这些大麻素受体。所以他们所做的是，他们有两组小鼠，在其中一组中，他们敲除了这些受体，即所谓的CB1受体，它们基本上不起作用。所以无论他们接受多少外部或内部的这种物质，
they were never going to get the effect. They then built this challenge, right? The mice could earn access to either the running wheel or a small chocolate treat, but they had to work for both. They had to push their nose against this device, basically like over and over again, and it got increasingly hard if they wanted the reward because they were testing motivation. What they found was pretty amazing. Mice with a strong working endocannabinoid system actually put in effort to exercise, choosing the running over the chocolate over and over again. And the mice without the cannabinoid receptors did not want anything to do with the wheel. They only kind of occasionally wanted something to do with the chocolate, but they definitely didn't want to run. The only thing that was different
他们永远不会得到那种效果。然后他们建立了这个挑战，对吧？小鼠可以获得跑步轮或小块巧克力作为奖励，但它们必须为两者付出努力。它们必须一次又一次地用鼻子推这个装置，如果它们想要奖励，难度会越来越大，因为他们在测试动力。他们发现的结果非常惊人。拥有运作良好的内源性大麻素系统的小鼠实际上付出了努力去运动，一次又一次地选择跑步而不是巧克力。而没有大麻素受体的小鼠根本不想碰那个轮子。它们只是偶尔想碰一下巧克力，但它们绝对不想跑。唯一不同的
was these receptors. So in other words, when these cannabinoid receptors aren't functioned, The mice didn't suddenly become lazy overall. They weren't lazy mice. There was just as part of them that lost interest in running. And the researchers takeaway was that these receptors play a major role in the motivation to exercise. That's why some people really love it. Some people don't. This is obviously a mouse study, but it does connect to this bigger idea that's been building in humans too. Some people naturally just do not find exercise as rewarding. Some people naturally could run 100 miles and never get that high. The question that comes from that is like, is it just their DNA? The answer is a bit more complicated. I think the best way to picture it is this loop whereby exercise actually increases endocanabinoids.
就是这些受体。换句话说，当这些大麻素受体不发挥作用时，小鼠并没有突然变得整体懒惰。它们不是懒惰的小鼠。只是它们的一部分对跑步失去了兴趣。研究人员的结论是，这些受体在运动动力中起着重要作用。这就是为什么有些人真的很喜欢它。有些人不喜欢。这显然是一项小鼠研究，但它确实与人类中正在建立的这个更大的想法相联系。有些人天生就是觉得运动没有那么有回报。有些人天生就能跑100英里却永远得不到那种快感。由此产生的问题是，这只是他们的DNA吗？答案有点复杂。我认为最好的想象方式是这个循环，即运动实际上增加了内源性大麻素。
Endocanabinoids can make exercise feel more rewarding, which makes you more likely to do it again, which then increases the level and increases how basically receptive. our receptors are to this chemical. This also is influenced by environment. So if you grew up in a family where nobody really ever exercised or exercise for you is always associated with discomfort, a social discomfort, an emotional discomfort, bullying, whatever, whatever number of these chemicals you have in your brain, it is always going to be harder to find motivation because the negative reinforcement of this poor past experience will often continuously outweigh the positive reinforcement of these catapenoids. Let's move on from this biological explanation. Let's talk about why
内源性大麻素可以使运动感觉更有回报，这使你更有可能再次进行运动，这反过来又增加了水平，并增加了我们的受体对这种化学物质的接受程度。这也受到环境的影响。所以如果你在一个没有人真正运动的家庭中长大，或者对你来说运动总是与不适、社交不适、情感不适、欺凌等联系在一起，无论你大脑中有多少这些化学物质，找到动力总是会更难，因为这种糟糕的过去经历的负面强化通常会持续超过这些内源性大麻素的正面强化。让我们从这个生物学解释中走出来。让我们谈谈为什么
exercise is so powerful from a semantic and emotional perspective, because I don't know about you. I don't exercise for the physicality of it. I don't exercise because of looks. I really exercise because I'm a very stressed individual, and exercise is one of the only coping strategies I have found that is not self-destructive. And I feel like I have tried a few others. This is because exercise is a form of somatic release. Basically, it is a way for our body to physically process emotions through sensation and movement. A lot of trauma, emotion is obviously psychological. So it's also deeply physical. It sits, it is stored in your body. If you have ever read the body keeps the score, you will know this, but trauma leaves its mark in.
运动从语义和情感的角度来看如此强大，因为我不知道你怎么样。我运动不是为了身体素质。我运动不是因为外表。我运动真的是因为我是一个压力很大的人，而运动是我发现的唯一不是自我毁灭的应对策略之一。我觉得我尝试过其他几种。这是因为运动是一种躯体释放。基本上，它是我们身体通过感觉和运动来物理处理情绪的一种方式。很多创伤、情绪显然是心理上的。所以它也深深地是身体上的。它坐落、储存在你的身体里。如果你读过《身体从未忘记》，你就会知道这一点，但创伤留下了它的印记，
so many ways in the form of a hyperactive nervous system, in the form of a constant sense of danger that can wreck havoc on your hormonal balance, stress levels, immune system, to work through stress and emotional trauma at some point we have to deal with this physical side. We have to feel safe enough to inhabit our bodies and safe enough for our bodies to return to homeostasis. when we move the movement gives those, I guess, tense or stuck energy somewhere to go. You know, for example, when you increase respiration and circulation through a run, this can shift your autonomic nervous system back on from fight and flight to a balanced response to rest and digest.
以多种方式，以过度活跃的神经系统的形式，以一种持续的危险感的形式，这会破坏你的荷尔蒙平衡、压力水平、免疫系统。为了处理压力和情感创伤，在某个时候我们必须处理这个身体层面。我们必须感到足够安全以居住在我们的身体中，并感到足够安全以让我们的身体恢复到稳态。当我们移动时，这种运动给了那些，我猜，紧张或卡住的能量一个去处。你知道，例如，当你通过跑步增加呼吸和循环时，这可以将你的自主神经系统从战斗和逃跑状态切换回平衡的休息和消化反应。
When we exercise, we also convert that weird, vague, floating anxiety that comes from stress into a specific bodily sensation. We begin to find it manageable. It also indicates to your brain, hey, like we encountered physical stress and we survived. Maybe when we encounter emotional stress that feels like physical stress in the future, will be psychologically resilient enough for that as well.
当我们运动时，我们还将那种来自压力的奇怪、模糊、漂浮的焦虑转化为一种特定的身体感觉。我们开始发现它是可控的。它也向你的大脑表明，嘿，我们遇到了身体压力，我们活下来了。也许当我们将来遇到感觉像身体压力的情感压力时，我们在心理上也会有足够的韧性来应对。
This is actually, this has a name in psychology. It's called stress inoculation theory, essentially exposing yourself to manageable, voluntary stress like running like exercise. It puts your body under a state of strain that then prepares it and allows it to practice coping mechanisms for when it's under stress and strain in the future, in an involuntary way. Finally, this is one of my favorite concepts ever. The reason exercise and specifically forward movement, like, walking, running, riding, hiking, horse riding even.
这实际上，这在心理学中有一个名字。它被称为压力接种理论，本质上是将自己暴露在可控的、自愿的压力下，比如跑步、运动。它使你的身体处于一种紧张状态，然后为它做好准备，并允许它练习应对机制，以便在未来处于非自愿的压力和紧张状态时使用。最后，这是我最喜欢的概念之一。运动，特别是向前运动，比如走路、跑步、骑行、徒步、甚至骑马，
The reason those are so good for you emotionally is because of the power of optic flow. Basically, you're like Hot Girl Walk is a form of therapy because your eyes make constant lateral movements to track your environment. This optic flow calms the brain's threat processing system and centers. It shifts you into a more relaxed emotional state that can do. change your thought patterns for the better. Literally, if you have heard of EDMR therapy, the creator of that therapy, Dr. Francine Shapiro, she conceived of that theory that is one of the most prominent in trauma therapy these days on a walk. She realized that when she was walking, those movements that her eyes were doing was reducing her stress levels. That is why for some people,
之所以对你的情绪如此有益，是因为视流的力量。基本上，你的“辣妹漫步”是一种治疗形式，因为你的眼睛不断进行横向运动来追踪你的环境。这种视流平息了大脑的威胁处理系统和中心。它将你转移到一个更放松的情绪状态，这可以改变你的思维模式，使其变得更好。字面上，如果你听说过EMDR治疗，该治疗的创始人弗朗辛·夏皮罗博士，她在一次散步中构思了那个理论，这是当今创伤治疗中最突出的理论之一。她意识到，当她走路时，她眼睛所做的那些运动正在降低她的压力水平。这就是为什么对有些人来说，
when they exercise, when they walk, when they hike, when they run, that is the only time their brain is still. it's the only time they don't overthink. Beyond all this, psychologically as well, I really just think that exercise helps us rewire our mind and change our cognitive frameworks because it gives us benchmarks to strive for because of the structure of it. You know, how fast can I run?
当他们运动时，当他们走路、徒步、跑步时，那是他们大脑静止的唯一时间。这是他们不胡思乱想的唯一时间。除此之外，在心理上，我也真的认为运动帮助我们重塑思维并改变我们的认知框架，因为它给了我们努力的基准，因为它的结构。你知道，我能跑多快？
Well, especially if you're focused on improvement, right? How fast can I run? How much further can I run? How much heavier can I lift? How many more reps can I do? how can I improve my form? How many more inches can I get? Benchmarks like that that are so obvious and available in exercise and sport are incredibly stabilizing for the human mind because they make progress visible. They give us a sense of control. I really think that's what it is. Like if we look and we think
嗯，特别是如果你专注于改进，对吧？我能跑多快？我能跑多远？我能举多重？我能做多少次重复？我怎样才能改善我的姿势？我能再多几英寸吗？像这样在运动和体育中如此明显和可用的基准对人类思维来说是极其稳定的，因为它们使进步可见。它们给了我们一种控制感。我真的认为这就是它。就像如果我们看，我们想
about the stress we experience in everyday life, a lot of it is external pressure that feels completely outside of us and we have no say in it. You know, we have no say. if somebody at work hates us. We have no say if we're having a fight with our friend. We have no say if, I don't know, we got scammed or we missed our bus, some of those things we have say in. But a lot of like the more general stress of living in big cities or being in your 20s, like it just kind of all gets thrown at us. Exercise creates controllable benchmarks that we can work towards systematically. You cannot discount this mental structure. study after study including a very famous one in 2018 from the University of Exeter and the University of New South Wales
关于我们在日常生活中经历的压力，很多是完全在我们之外的外部压力，我们对此没有发言权。你知道，我们没有发言权。如果工作中的某个人讨厌我们。如果我们在和朋友吵架，我们没有发言权。如果我们，我不知道，被骗了或者错过了公交车，我们没有发言权，其中一些事情我们有发言权。但很多像生活在大城市或20多岁时更普遍的压力，就像它只是被扔向我们。运动创造了我们可以系统地努力实现的可控基准。你不能忽视这种心理结构。一项又一项的研究，包括2018年埃克塞特大学和新南威尔士大学的一项非常著名的研究，
shows that structure like this, the mental structure of exercise reverses mental aging, improves emotional functioning, reduces your risk factor for dementia. Even if you hate exercise, this is so important to know because you probably won't hate exercise as much as you will hate losing your memory as you get older. And this is one of the best ways you can protect against that. Let's talk about the final element of exercise that makes it so powerful. It is the social psychology behind co-regulation. Doing exercise by yourself, amazing.
表明这种结构，运动的心理结构可以逆转心理衰老，改善情绪功能，降低你患痴呆症的风险。即使你讨厌运动，了解这一点也非常重要，因为你可能不会像讨厌随着年龄增长而失去记忆那样讨厌运动。这是你可以预防这种情况的最佳方法之一。让我们谈谈运动的最后一个使其如此强大的元素。这就是共调节背后的社会心理学。自己一个人运动，很棒。
Doing at least one workout a week with others is spectacular for every single element of your health that you can think of. There is something uniquely regulating about doing something next to somebody, not necessarily facing them, not necessarily talking deeply, just moving alongside them. Side-by-side movement like that is one of our most primal states of being. It's one of the most rewarding sensations. It unlocks this deep, ancient peace in you because that is how we were meant to move across plains, across mountains with other people, naturally as a pack side by side for thousands of years.
每周至少和别人一起锻炼一次，对你能想到的你健康的每一个元素来说都是壮观的。在某人旁边做某事，不一定面对面，不一定深入交谈，只是在他们旁边移动，有一种独特的调节作用。像那样的并排运动是我们最原始的存在状态之一。它是最有回报的感觉之一。它解锁了你内心深处古老的平静，因为这就是我们注定要跨越平原、跨越山脉与其他人一起移动的方式，几千年来自然地作为一个群体并排移动。
Thousands of years before we got here. That is hardwired into your DNA for that to be a relaxing, mood stabilizing sensation that you are with the herd, you are protected, you are moving forward. In fact, research on this, what they call physical synchrony shows that it increases bonding, it increases affiliation. Interestingly, it can even shift and downgrade pain tolerance. Literally, your run club is reducing your perception of pain. The best example of this published in the research was a journal from a couple of years ago on group dancing, and it showed that, yeah, dancing is great, but when you dance with other people,
在我们来到这里之前的几千年。这已经深深植入你的DNA中，让你感到这是一种放松、情绪稳定的感觉，你和群体在一起，你受到保护，你在前进。事实上，对此的研究，他们称之为身体同步，表明它增加了联系，增加了归属感。有趣的是，它甚至可以转移和降低疼痛耐受性。字面上，你的跑步俱乐部正在降低你对疼痛的感知。研究中发表的对此的最佳例子是几年前关于集体舞蹈的一本期刊，它表明，是的，跳舞很棒，但当你和别人一起跳舞时，
it improves emotional coping. people felt better able to handle hard situations when they got out and danced. When they were dancing with other people in a group setting, even at the club, in the old person's home, like that movement is ancient, is an ancient ritual. Physical movement is a spiritual ritual in this sense that unlocks a core, I think a core need in us that not many activities in the modern day will naturally do. That is really our first takeaway from the psychology of exercise. It's not just good for you because of endorphins.
它改善了情绪应对。当人们出去跳舞时，他们感到更有能力处理困难的情况。当他们在群体环境中与其他人一起跳舞时，即使是在俱乐部，在养老院，那种运动是古老的，是一种古老的仪式。身体运动在这个意义上是一种精神仪式，它解锁了我们内心的一种核心需求，我认为是现代生活中没有多少活动会自然做到的。这就是我们从运动心理学中得到的第一个要点。它不仅仅是因为内啡肽对你有好处。
Therefore, it doesn't only benefit you if you're pushing yourself to the physical limit every time. There are so many other reasons why even just walking, yoga, low-impact exercise is just as vital and helpful. Because of somatic release, because of co-regulation, because of physical synchrony. Okay, let's take a short break here. Before we get into discussing how exercise changes our brains, whether it is or could ever be a replacement for antidepressants, as some suggest. Some of those more controversial sides to this topic we're going to get into after the short break. Stay with us.
因此，它不仅仅在你每次都将自己推向身体极限时才对你有益。还有很多其他原因，为什么即使只是走路、瑜伽、低冲击运动也同样重要和有帮助。因为躯体释放，因为共调节，因为身体同步。好了，我们在这里休息一下。在我们开始讨论运动如何改变我们的大脑，它是否是或可能永远是抗抑郁药的替代品（正如一些人所建议的那样）之前。这个话题中一些更具争议的一面，我们将在短暂休息后深入探讨。请留下来。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等交谈，以看透统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在I-Hart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。需要明确的是，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我整天都愿意谈论快克，但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病，所以。谢谢你完成那句话。是的，我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have.
生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现作为一个好人很重要，当你活在地球上时。你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，让我们进行
have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd
关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话，就在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过
been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·纳拉尼尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着这一季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们，先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never. mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he just serves. Listen to the girlfriends.
规则二，永远不要。招惹她的朋友。我们总是说要相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》这一新季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的报应。请收听《The Girlfriends:
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Regular exercise will literally change the physical structure of your brain. That is a claim a lot of people make. Let's explore it together. There is no doubt, really, that exercise will physically change your brain. But it's not going to create like new lobes or anything. Primarily, it's going to increase what we call brain volume.
Trust Me, Babe》。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。规律的运动会字面上改变你大脑的物理结构。这是很多人提出的主张。让我们一起探索它。毫无疑问，运动会物理性地改变你的大脑。但它不会创造像新的脑叶之类的东西。主要是，它会增加我们所说的脑容量。
and it's also going to promote functional changes as well. So when you hear somebody be like, it changes your brain, it's not giving a new brain, it's changing how networks in your brain communicate. If we look structurally, one of the most famous findings about the neurological impact of exercise comes from this randomized trial showing that people who did aerobic exercise tend to have increased hippocampal volume. So the hippocampus, basically it's involved in learning and memory. More volume in those areas means greater memory abilities.
它也会促进功能性变化。所以当你听到有人说“它改变了你的大脑”时，它不是给你一个新大脑，它是在改变你大脑中的网络如何沟通。如果我们从结构上看，关于运动对神经影响的最著名的发现之一来自这项随机试验，显示进行有氧运动的人往往海马体体积增加。所以海马体，基本上它参与学习和记忆。这些区域的体积越大，意味着记忆能力越强。
It means more brain reserves, more neurons, more white matter, greater hydration from more cells being able to hold water. That's all very important for electrical signaling. So that change in volume influences the change in function. This 2011 University of Illinois study trial, I guess, actually looked at 120 older adults and it asked them to engage either in regular walking, starting at 10 minutes, going up to 40 minutes, or it asked them just to stretch. They then did a number of before, during, and after MRIs. And what they found was that in these older adults, the hippocampus, the part that usually really
这意味着更多的大脑储备、更多的神经元、更多的白质、更多细胞能够保持水分带来的更大水合作用。这对电信号传导非常重要。所以体积的变化影响了功能的变化。这项2011年伊利诺伊大学的研究试验，我猜，实际上观察了120名老年人，并要求他们进行规律的步行，从10分钟开始，增加到40分钟，或者要求他们只是做伸展运动。他们随后进行了多次之前、期间和之后的核磁共振成像。他们发现的是，在这些老年人中，海马体，那个通常真的
shows a decline in age and that naturally shrinks was staying really strong and healthy, showing less deterioration and sometimes an increase in volume in people who were walking regularly. The craziest statistic from the study, the average volume increase was 2%. That equals 1 to 2 years of reversal of age-related volume loss. Basically, they were getting years back of their memory, of their lives, of the plasticity of their brain. And that's really important to emphasize. I think when you do an episode about the psychology of exercise, right, people want you to like emphasize how intense exercise is probably great for you. And you're probably assuming that working out vigorously would increase anaerobic, aerobic,
显示出年龄衰退并且自然萎缩的部分，保持得非常强壮和健康，显示出更少的恶化，有时在规律步行的人中体积有所增加。这项研究中最疯狂的统计数据，平均体积增加了2%。这相当于逆转了1到2年的年龄相关体积损失。基本上，他们找回了几年记忆、生活、大脑可塑性的时间。这真的非常重要，需要强调。我认为当你做一集关于运动心理学的节目时，对吧，人们希望你强调运动强度可能对你有多好。你可能认为剧烈锻炼会增加无氧、有氧、
blood circulation, digestion, all these things that would help with this mental longevity and physical longevity. What these studies are showing us is that intensity doesn't matter. all that matters is consistency. All that matters is how much were they doing? 40 minutes, 40 minutes a day and you are reversing, you are getting years back on your life. And I think that that knowledge is important for people who don't always have the best relationship with exercise or people who think that it is, yeah, again, intensity that's going to matter. Absolutely not. In terms of the more functional changes, exercise also improves basically. how your different brain networks talk to each other. Your brain has these big systems that switch on
血液循环、消化，所有这些有助于这种心理长寿和身体长寿的事情。这些研究向我们展示的是，强度并不重要。重要的是坚持。重要的是他们做了多少？每天40分钟，你就在逆转，你就在找回几年的生命。我认为这些知识对于那些与运动关系不太好的人，或者认为这又是强度才重要的人来说很重要。绝对不是。在功能性变化方面，运动也改善了基本上。你不同大脑网络之间如何交谈。你的大脑有这些大系统，它们会根据
depending on what you're doing. One network you hear a lot about in the podcast, the default mode network is more active when like you're daydreaming or you're stuck in self-focused thought patterns and another network, which is the executive control network, is more active when you're concentrating, planning, controlling your attention. A 2025 review of functional connectivity and the relationship it has with exercise revealed that people who exercise regularly can switch between these networks easier. Basically, it nudges your brain to have better coping, to become more flexible and to have smoother switching, meaning you don't just stick in one mode. We're not always either on or feeling a little bit off or detached.
你正在做的事情而切换。你在播客中经常听到的一个网络，默认模式网络，当你像做白日梦或陷入自我关注的思维模式时更活跃，而另一个网络，执行控制网络，当你集中注意力、计划、控制你的注意力时更活跃。2025年对功能连接及其与运动关系的回顾显示，经常运动的人可以更容易地在这些网络之间切换。基本上，它推动你的大脑有更好的应对能力，变得更灵活，并有更平滑的切换，这意味着你不会只停留在一种模式中。我们并不总是要么处于开启状态，要么感觉有点不对劲或脱离状态。
regular exercise means that we can retune that kind of network balance to help our brain shift gears between self-focused thought and goal-directed thought more efficiently. And that's great for mental resilience. Now, what does this all mean for our mental health? We have to get to it. We've been circling this element all day for this whole episode. Something that has become a huge annoyance of mine is very old. And I would say increasingly boring narrative that exercise is better than any antidepressant.
规律的运动意味着我们可以重新调整那种网络平衡，帮助大脑更有效地在自我专注思维和目标导向思维之间切换。这对心理韧性非常有益。那么，这一切对我们的心理健康意味着什么呢？我们必须深入探讨。在这一整集中，我们一直在围绕这个话题。有一件事让我非常恼火，那就是一个非常古老且日益无聊的说法：运动比任何抗抑郁药都有效。
If you're depressed, put on your running shoes, you don't need a pill, you need some new sneakers, you need to get off the couch and go for a run. I remember a famous TikTok about that a couple of years ago. I don't know, I trained for a half marathon last year. I was running like 35 kilometers a week. I was also on antidepressants and I was still depressed. So unless you want to say they cancelled each other out, something isn't adding up. Exercise is not the holy grail.
如果你抑郁了，穿上跑鞋，你不需要药丸，你需要的是新运动鞋，你需要离开沙发去跑步。我记得几年前有一个关于这个的著名TikTok视频。我不知道，我去年为半程马拉松进行了训练。我每周跑大约35公里。我也在服用抗抑郁药，但我仍然感到抑郁。所以，除非你想说它们相互抵消了，否则有些事情是说不通的。运动并不是万灵药。
I think so many people think it is. I think this belief has gotten worse in recent years because of one very famous study from 2024. This is a paper that went viral. Academic articles so rarely go viral. And this paper essentially looked at the results of 19 different studies measuring the effects of dancing on depression in older adults. And it found that those who took part in dance interventions actually saw a significant reduction in depression compared to those who didn't. That's what
我想很多人都认为它是。我认为这种信念在近年来因为2024年的一项非常著名的研究而变得更加严重。这是一篇疯传的学术论文。学术文章很少能疯传。这篇论文本质上查看了19项不同研究的结果，这些研究测量了舞蹈对老年人抑郁症的影响。研究发现，与没有参加舞蹈干预的人相比，参加舞蹈干预的人抑郁症状确实有显著减轻。这就是
the blanket finding was. If we think back to the synchrony research that we talked about earlier, like that makes a little sense, right? We're moving with other people. It's this natural rhythm. but the issue is this paper only included 19 randomized studies. That's only 500 people all up in these studies. Even themselves, even the researchers themselves said the findings of this paper were high risk for generalization and were probably very low in terms of validity, so the fact that they could be produced again and again and again. So we have to acknowledge there are holes in this research.
笼统的结论。如果我们回想一下我们之前谈到的同步性研究，这有点道理，对吧？我们与其他人一起运动。这是一种自然的节奏。但问题是，这篇论文只包含了19项随机研究。这些研究总共只有500人。即使是研究人员自己也表示，这篇论文的结论泛化风险很高，在有效性方面可能非常低，也就是说，它们能否被反复验证还很难说。所以我们必须承认这项研究存在漏洞。
There was another study that also got a lot of hype that was very similar to this one, titled Exercise for Depression, very to the point title. This research basically published a finding about how exercise can improve depressive symptoms, which is true, but a lot of people online took that out of context and said, this is proof that mentally ill people just need to exercise more. The important caveat, these findings were compared to no treatment, not antidepressants, not therapy. Basically, they had two groups of people.
还有另一项研究也受到了很多炒作，与这项研究非常相似，标题为《运动治疗抑郁症》，标题非常直截了当。这项研究基本上发表了一个关于运动如何改善抑郁症状的发现，这是事实，但网上的许多人断章取义，说这是证明精神疾病患者只需要多运动的证据。重要的警告是，这些发现是与不进行任何治疗进行比较，而不是与抗抑郁药或心理治疗进行比较。基本上，他们有两组人。
One group was a depressed group of people who didn't do any intervention, including exercise. One was a depressed group of people who the only intervention was exercise. That's why they got better. That's why they felt better. It wasn't a cure. You know, it was this difference between doing nothing and something. That's something, you know, a lot of people said could have been anything. I really do think that exercise is a very very important.
一组是抑郁症患者，他们没有进行任何干预，包括运动。另一组是抑郁症患者，他们唯一的干预措施是运动。这就是他们好转的原因。这就是他们感觉更好的原因。这不是治愈。你知道，这只是什么都不做和做点什么之间的区别。那“做点什么”，你知道，很多人说可能是什么都可以。我确实认为运动是非常、非常重要的。
very, very valuable part of mental health treatment. I genuinely think I would lose my mind if I did not run regularly. And I've got so many friends who have said very similar things. We have to be really careful with generalizations, though. We have to be incredibly specific because the consequences of saying, dance will cure your depression. Dance was better than any antidepressant. Running was better than any therapy treatment offered is supremely dangerous because there are people out there. You know, I feel like I'm probably one of them. You're probably, we all know somebody out there who's really doing it tough and looking for a solution.
非常、非常有价值的心理健康治疗的一部分。我真心认为，如果我不定期跑步，我会疯掉的。我有许多朋友也说过类似的话。但是，我们必须非常谨慎地进行概括。我们必须非常具体，因为说“跳舞能治愈你的抑郁症”、“跳舞比任何抗抑郁药都好”、“跑步比任何提供的心理治疗都好”，这种后果是极其危险的，因为外面有很多人。你知道，我觉得我可能就是其中之一。你可能也认识，我们都知道外面有人真的过得很艰难，正在寻找解决方案。
And to say your antidepressants or your whatever other methods or interventions are getting in the way of the purity of exercise and the purity of results you could get from exercise is deeply dangerous. and really just excludes other parts, you know, of the truth. Okay, let's move on from this. Let's pivot from this, should I say. Let's get into the deeper relationship between exercise and mental health beyond it is a treatment for depression or anxiety.
说你的抗抑郁药或其他任何方法或干预措施阻碍了运动的纯粹性以及你从运动中可能获得的纯粹结果，这是极其危险的，而且真的只是排除了真相的其他部分。好了，让我们从这里继续。让我们从这里转换一下话题。让我们深入探讨运动与心理健康之间更深层的关系，超越它作为抑郁症或焦虑症的治疗方法这一层面。
When does exercise actually become bad for our mental health and our psychology? Here is something you may not know about me. My sister is actually a professional athlete. She plays football. My mom was also a professional athlete, or elite athlete. She was a javelin thrower. She played men's basketball back in the day when they didn't have a women's team. I did not get that gene, obviously. One of my best friends, also a professional athlete. I have heard stories, horror stories of how obsessive people will get. People doing 10K races when they had been warned by
运动什么时候真的会对我们的心理健康和心理状态产生负面影响？这里有一件你可能不知道关于我的事。我姐姐其实是一名职业运动员。她踢足球。我妈妈也是一名职业运动员，或者说精英运动员。她是标枪运动员。她在那个还没有女子队的年代打过男子篮球。显然，我没有遗传到那个基因。我最好的朋友之一也是职业运动员。我听过一些恐怖故事，关于人们会变得多么痴迷。人们在被医生警告后，
dox is not to do it because of heart impairments. People tearing muscles and going back to the gym the next day. The diet, the control, the obsession, everything, the stories they will tell you. There is a growing amount of research on what we could now call exercise addiction, uncontrolled, excessive exercise that persists even when it causes you harm. That behavioral pattern is very similar to other addictions. There's a bit of controversy as to whether we could call it an addiction, but I think it is. A massive reason being, it works on very similar neurological levels and biological levels. Exercise has this amazing potential to change our mood. It provides this rare combination of things, which is immediate relief and measurable progress, as well as social reinforcement and moral
因为心脏损伤而不要参加10公里比赛，但他们还是去了。人们肌肉撕裂，第二天又回到健身房。饮食、控制、痴迷，所有的一切，他们会告诉你的故事。关于我们现在可以称之为“运动成瘾”的研究越来越多，即即使在造成伤害时仍然持续进行的、不受控制的过度运动。这种行为模式与其他成瘾非常相似。关于我们是否可以称之为成瘾，存在一些争议，但我认为它是。一个巨大的原因是，它在非常相似的神经学和生物学层面上起作用。运动具有改变我们情绪的惊人潜力。它提供了一种罕见的组合，即即时的缓解和可衡量的进步，以及社会强化和道德
validation. For somebody who feels lost, for somebody who feels powerless, you know, ecstasy, heroin, might not be their drug of choice. Exercise very easily could be, because it gives you something to focus on. If you have all these areas in your life that feel uncontrollable, relationships, work, family, money, exercise can become the domain where control feels possible. This isn't inherently bad, but it can become dangerous when that attempt at gaining control becomes compulsive. A lot of exercise addiction. research that is, you know, coming out at the moment really highlights the overlap between
认可。对于一个感到迷茫的人，对于一个感到无力的人，你知道，摇头丸、海洛因可能不是他们的首选药物。运动很容易成为，因为它给了你一个可以专注的目标。如果你的生活中所有这些领域都让你感到无法控制，比如人际关系、工作、家庭、金钱，运动可以成为你觉得可以控制的领域。这本身并不坏，但当这种获得控制的尝试变成强迫性时，它就会变得危险。目前出现的很多关于运动成瘾的研究，
exercise and body image issues and exercise and eating disorders and the fact that you lose the joy for progress. It's about management. It's about shame. It's about self-worth. It's about control. Because of this, like, exercise can become a way that somebody manages their emotions. Yes, it can also become the way that people manage. their identity. You know, you feel panicked, you feel guilty, you feel low, you feel bad about yourself. Exercise is the emotional regulator. And when it becomes the only method for that, it becomes really confining because it will, like life will eventually interrupt it. You know, when you experience illness, injury, travel, you have caring responsibility, school, grief, burnout, and you cannot
真的强调了运动与身体形象问题、运动与饮食失调之间的重叠，以及你失去了进步的乐趣这一事实。这是关于管理。这是关于羞耻感。这是关于自我价值。这是关于控制。正因为如此，运动可以成为某人管理情绪的一种方式。是的，它也可以成为人们管理身份的方式。你知道，你感到恐慌，你感到内疚，你感到低落，你对自己感觉不好。运动是情绪调节器。当它成为唯一的调节方法时，它就变得非常局限，因为生活最终会打断它。你知道，当你经历疾病、受伤、旅行、你有照顾责任、学业、悲伤、倦怠时，你无法
stick to the rigid schedule anymore. If your emotional stability depends on never missing a session, you are building mental health on a very rocky foundation. The thing is, exercise and self-esteem have this very complicated relationship, right? On one hand, exercise can really encourage self-esteem because it improves, like, it improves mastery, which we know is very psychologically important. It improves competence. It improves agency, all things that give us a real identity boost, all things that are very important. It also improves trust in yourself. Like, look, I can rely on myself to do this. I can rely on myself to be strong. Research supports this. It supports the positive link between self-esteem and physical
再坚持那种僵化的时间表了。如果你的情绪稳定取决于从不缺席一次训练，那么你就是在非常不稳固的基础上建立心理健康。问题是，运动和自尊有着非常复杂的关系，对吧？一方面，运动确实可以促进自尊，因为它提高了，比如，它提高了掌控感，我们知道这在心理上非常重要。它提高了能力感。它提高了自主性，所有这些都给了我们真正的身份提升，所有这些都非常重要。它还提高了对自己的信任。比如，看，我可以依靠自己来做这件事。我可以依靠自己变得强大。研究支持这一点。它支持自尊与身体活动之间的正向联系。
activity. However, sometimes it goes too far and it becomes the only thing that makes us feel good about ourselves, not just the only thing that makes us feel good about ourselves emotionally, but physically. And that is when it begins to worsen self-esteem, because it becomes a performance of worth. It might feel like exercise only counts if you are the best at something, or if you are feeling like you need to pass out at the end, or if you are getting certain times, hitting certain reps, progress is only progress if it is perfect. Another common thought that begins to bubble up is that rest or rest days are lazy, which if you think about it is, you know, a deeper topic about our relationship with slowing down. But in these mindsets, really exercise becomes a form
然而，有时它走得太远，它成了唯一让我们对自己感觉良好的东西，不仅是唯一让我们在情感上感觉良好的东西，而且是在身体上。这就是它开始损害自尊的时候，因为它变成了一种价值的表演。它可能感觉好像只有当你在某方面是最好的，或者如果你感觉自己在结束时需要昏倒，或者如果你达到了特定的时间、完成了特定的重复次数，运动才算数，进步只有在完美时才是进步。另一个开始涌现的常见想法是，休息或休息日是懒惰的，如果你仔细想想，这是一个关于我们与放慢节奏之间关系的更深层话题。但在这些心态中，运动确实成为了一种
of conditional self-acceptance. It becomes this thing whereby you have to earn feeling good about yourself. This self-acceptance, much like the kind of emotional regulation that comes from exercise, never sticks around for too long, because the goalpost will constantly move, especially if it also becomes tied in with how you see yourself physically. If it is a method of changing physical form and society's ideal physical form is always changing, like you are never going to be happy and no matter how much control exercise gives you. Because again, the goalpost always changes. Okay, let's move on from this a little bit and talk about early experiences,
有条件的自我接纳。它变成了一种你必须通过它来赢得对自己感觉良好的东西。这种自我接纳，就像运动带来的情绪调节一样，从来不会持续太久，因为目标会不断移动，特别是如果它也与你如何看待自己的身体联系在一起的话。如果它是改变身体形态的一种方法，而社会理想的身体形态总是在变化，那么无论运动给你多少控制感，你永远都不会快乐。因为同样，目标总是会变。好了，让我们从这里稍微转换一下，谈谈早期的经历，
exercise and how they linger, how they hurt or help our relationship with movement. This is the thing I'm deeply fascinated by because many people's relationship with exercise for a lot of us was formed like way before social media, at least if like you are in your 20s, mid to late early 20s. Often we experience exercise at school or like with family as our first experience. And literally the split that I see in society between people who loved PE and people who hated PE also tends to split like how adult love of exercise versus our hatred. Like it genuinely so much of it comes down to this like childhood experience. And if you are sitting there being like, I've never been able to love exercise the way that I thought I could
运动以及它们如何挥之不去，它们如何伤害或帮助我们与运动的关系。这是我非常着迷的事情，因为对于我们很多人来说，与运动的关系在社交媒体出现之前就已经形成了，至少如果你是在20多岁，20多岁出头或中后期。我们通常在学校或家庭中第一次体验运动。而且我看到的社会中，喜欢体育课的人和讨厌体育课的人之间的分歧，往往也分化了成年后对运动的喜爱与厌恶。这真的很大程度上归结于这种童年经历。如果你坐在那里想，我从来没能像我想象的那样喜欢运动，
or the way that others could, it is worth having a look back at those times. In 2022, two researchers from Middle Sex University published a qualitative piece of research, which essentially did just this. They had like, I don't know how many participants. I think it was like hundreds of thousands. Oh, hundreds or thousands, not hundreds of thousands. And it basically was like, what did you think about PE class? Were you embarrassed?
或者像其他人那样喜欢，回顾那些时光是值得的。2022年，来自米德尔塞克斯大学的两名研究人员发表了一篇定性研究，本质上就是做了这件事。他们有，我不知道有多少参与者。我想是几百或几千人，哦，几百或几千，不是几十万人。它基本上是问，你对体育课有什么看法？你感到尴尬吗？
Did you have fun? Were you always picked? Were you not picked? Consistently they found negative memories linger into adult. and it shaped how people felt in exercise later on. If they would go into a group class and they felt judged, they would never go back. If they went to a run club and they felt like left behind, or they didn't have the right shoes, like they would exit, they wouldn't want to be there.
你玩得开心吗？你总是被选中吗？你没被选中吗？他们一致发现，负面记忆会持续到成年，并塑造了人们后来对运动的感觉。如果他们去参加集体课程并感到被评判，他们就再也不会去了。如果他们去跑步俱乐部并感到被落下，或者他们没有合适的鞋子，他们就会退出，他们不想待在那里。
And this is not surprising. What is happening in those moments, in those moments of shame, is that people feel judged and they feel insecure about their ability. they feel shame about their bodies. They feel shame in comparison to their peers. And we know that shame is one of the most powerful motivators, especially for stopping something and especially for feeling like this isn't, this isn't for me. This isn't something that I'm going to do with my life. If you learnt that exercise equated to being embarrassed in your body, well, you know, you're never going to instinctively want to do it. You're never going to feel like it's something that naturally
这并不奇怪。在那些时刻，在那些羞耻的时刻，发生的事情是人们感到被评判，对自己的能力感到不安全。他们对自己的身体感到羞耻。他们在与同龄人的比较中感到羞耻。我们知道，羞耻感是最强大的动力之一，特别是对于停止某件事，特别是对于感觉“这不适合我”、“这不是我生活中要做的事情”。如果你学到运动等同于在身体上感到尴尬，那么，你知道，你永远不会本能地想要去做它。你永远不会觉得它是自然而然地
kind of comes across your plate. This is why a lot of people out there can logically understand the benefits of exercise and still dread it, still fear it, still hate the idea of it. So this is how I think we regain that healthy relationship to exercise. This is why it is so important to do exercise you love. I personally think a large part of our relationship to exercise in our teen years in our early, like very early 20s is exercise as self-punishment. Most of us have not yet formed this idea that movement is freedom or movement is privilege. Often what we do is we exercise in the way that we think is going to mold our body into the thing that is trending at the time. You really have to find autonomy and delight if you want
出现在你面前的事情。这就是为什么外面很多人在逻辑上可以理解运动的好处，但仍然害怕它、恐惧它、讨厌它的想法。所以这就是我认为我们如何重新获得与运动的健康关系。这就是为什么做你喜欢的运动如此重要。我个人认为，我们在青少年时期和20岁出头时与运动的关系很大程度上是作为自我惩罚。我们大多数人还没有形成这种观念，即运动是自由或运动是特权。我们经常做的是，我们以我们认为能把身体塑造成当时流行趋势的方式进行运动。如果你想
to be good at exercise, if you want to feel good about exercise, if you want to get those psychological benefits. Because there's evidence that pushing yourself to an extreme level time after time, pushing yourself to do things your body doesn't want to do and doesn't feel capable of before it is ready, like genuinely can sometimes reverse some of the positive impacts of exercise. there is an initial boost of being like, wow, look at me, I can do hot things. There is the initial circulatory boost, the initial respiratory boost, the initial physical boost. But if you perform any behavior, exercise included out of hatred, the psychological benefit of it
擅长运动，如果你想对运动感觉良好，如果你想获得那些心理益处，你真的必须找到自主权和快乐。因为有证据表明，一次又一次地把自己推向极端，强迫自己做身体不想做、在准备好之前感觉无法胜任的事情，确实有时会抵消运动的一些积极影响。最初会有那种“哇，看看我，我能做很酷的事情”的提升。有最初的循环提升、最初的呼吸提升、最初的身体提升。但如果你出于仇恨而进行任何行为，包括运动，那么它的心理益处
and the emotional benefit of it is always going to be underscored by that shame and is always going to be underscored by that pain. If you do exercise that you enjoy, even if it is, not as strenuous, you are more likely to keep going with it. You are more likely to set those benchmarks. You are more likely to avoid all or nothing thinking and the all or nothing spiral that sends you into a period of exercise abstinence. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience.
和情感益处总是会被那种羞耻感所削弱，总是会被那种痛苦所削弱。如果你做你喜欢的运动，即使它不那么剧烈，你也更有可能坚持下去。你更有可能设定那些基准。你更有可能避免非黑即白的思维，以及那种让你陷入一段运动禁欲期的非黑即白的螺旋。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。
in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happy, you're more fulfilled, healthier person.
在我们这个奇怪的现代世界里。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等进行交谈，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“TWO%”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选一年，拆解发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
我整天都可以谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克，有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要。你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场证明真相的多年法庭斗争。
I doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marincini.
我篡改了这个特定的测试两次，这么多。我篡改了测试一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马林奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎不在乎，所以她们采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友》。
Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. A great way to decipher what exercise might be your exercise is to think about why you're doing it and why you enjoy it. Maybe you like walking because you listen to a podcast while you're doing it. Maybe you like dancing because it feels expressive. Maybe you like swimming because it's the only time. you can focus. Maybe you like strength training because it makes you feel strong. If you genuinely are doing an exercise and you are sitting on that Pilates mat or you are sitting behind that barbell and
相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。解读什么运动可能是你的运动的一个好方法是思考你为什么要做它以及为什么你喜欢它。也许你喜欢走路，因为你在做的时候听播客。也许你喜欢跳舞，因为它感觉很有表现力。也许你喜欢游泳，因为这是唯一的时间。你可以专注。也许你喜欢力量训练，因为它让你感觉强壮。如果你真的在做一项运动，而你坐在那个普拉提垫上，或者你坐在那个杠铃后面，并且
the entire time you're like, this sucks. Find another exercise. Like there is a million classes. The amount of videos I see of people doing the most ridiculously funny, I will admit, but kind of like seemingly very fun exercises, it's astounding. There is something for everybody. I literally saw, you know what I've been seeing a lot is those people with those moon boots that have like trampolines on the bottom. People doing like trapeze exercise. You know what class I do at the moment that I freaking love is like Pilates in a sauna.
整个过程中你都在想，这太烂了。找另一项运动。就像有数百万种课程。我看到的关于人们做最荒谬、最有趣（我承认），但看起来非常有趣的运动的视频数量，令人震惊。每个人都有适合自己的东西。我真的看到了，你知道我经常看到的是那些穿着底部有蹦床的月球靴的人。人们做类似空中飞人的运动。你知道我现在上的什么课，我超级喜欢，就是桑拿普拉提。
Fitness, health and fitness, health and wellness is a billion dollar. Maybe even at this point trillion dollar money making machine. You can find I promise an exercise you enjoy more than running. or you enjoy more than, I don't know, I don't want to say like specific workouts, but more than like weight workouts or like high hit rep workouts. I also think we need to get out of this mindset that if you're not amazing at something, if you're not dying at the gym, every day, every weekend, like you're lazy. What causes us to believe that? What's the danger of that?
健身、健康与健身、健康与保健是一个十亿美元，甚至现在可能是万亿美元的赚钱机器。我保证你能找到一项你比跑步更喜欢的运动。或者你比，我不知道，我不想说具体的锻炼，但比举重锻炼或高强度间歇训练更喜欢的运动。我也认为我们需要摆脱这种心态：如果你不擅长某件事，如果你不是每天、每个周末都在健身房里累得半死，你就是懒惰。是什么导致我们相信这一点？那有什么危险？
I know a lot of times where, you know, we're held back by this thought of like, well, if I'm not doing this very well, like, is my body feeling it? Or if I'm not doing it, how everybody else is doing it, is it even worth it? Or am I embarrassing myself by showing up in this environment where I know I'm the one who knows the least? This comes down to everything. The impact of comparison, social media, childhood shame, perfectionism, all or nothing thinking, I need you to realize that nobody cares. Nobody cares. And your body is for you.
我知道很多时候，你知道，我们被这种想法所阻碍，比如，好吧，如果我做得不好，我的身体感觉到了吗？或者如果我不像其他人那样做，它值得吗？或者我通过出现在这个我知道自己知道得最少的环境中让自己尴尬吗？这归结为一切。比较的影响、社交媒体、童年羞耻感、完美主义、非黑即白的思维，我需要你意识到没有人关心。没有人关心。你的身体是为你自己的。
And if you find enjoyment through movement, even if it's the wrong kind of movement, even if people don't think you're doing it right, even if you're not doing it to the level that everybody else is doing, it does not matter. Your enjoyment and the fact that you are doing it is the only thing that does. Going slow, especially if you don't exercise regularly or if you're getting back into it, is the best way to go far. There was a study from The Lancet found that just five extra minutes of exercise and 30 minutes less sitting time each day will help you live longer. Brisk walks five minutes a day.
如果你通过运动找到乐趣，即使是错误的运动方式，即使人们认为你做得不对，即使你没有达到其他人那样的水平，这都无关紧要。你的享受和你正在做这件事的事实是唯一重要的。慢慢来，特别是如果你不经常运动或者正在恢复运动，是走得更远的最佳方式。《柳叶刀》的一项研究发现，每天多运动五分钟，少坐30分钟，将帮助你活得更长。每天快走五分钟。
That was a reduction, I think, in 10% of premature deaths across 135,000 people. that is huge and it just goes to show us that exercise doesn't need to be this huge overhaul life commitment. All it requires is a consistent commitment to your well-being to see the psychological impact, to see the neurological impact, the emotional impact, the physical impact. If you do not let your body guide you in a way that is going to be sustainable and healthy, If you exercise as a form of self-punishment rather than self-respect, I actually just think that all of those benefits are removed in an instant. You have to find the exercise you love, the exercise you enjoy, make it part of your routine as a form of self-care. Putting yourself in an exercise routine that you like, even if it's not as physically demanding as one you don't.
我想，这在135,000人中减少了10%的过早死亡。这非常巨大，它只是向我们表明，运动不需要成为这种巨大的生活承诺。它所需要的只是对你幸福的一贯承诺，以看到心理影响、神经影响、情感影响、身体影响。如果你不以一种可持续和健康的方式让你的身体引导你，如果你把运动作为一种自我惩罚而不是自我尊重的方式，我实际上认为所有这些好处都会瞬间消失。你必须找到你喜欢的运动，你享受的运动，把它作为一种自我保健的一部分融入你的日常生活中。把你置于一个你喜欢的运动常规中，即使它不像你不喜欢的那个那样对身体要求那么高。
personally, I actually think that's better for you if it means that you are going. Okay, this has been a long episode. If you're listening to this episode at the gym, by the way, or on a run, leave a comment. I need to know. DM me. I need to know if, because it would be, I don't know, kind of forthwally, kind of breaking the dimension here. If you're learning about what's happening in your body whilst you are doing that activity.
就个人而言，我实际上认为如果这意味着你会坚持下去，那对你更好。好了，这一集很长。顺便说一句，如果你在健身房或跑步时听这一集，请留下评论。我需要知道。私信我。我需要知道，因为这会是，我不知道，有点打破第四面墙，有点打破维度。如果你在做那项活动的同时了解你的身体正在发生什么。
But to summarize, again, to summarize this episode, exercise feels good for a lot of reasons. It is not just endorphins. We know it's also endocannabinoids. It's also the pain system. It's also somatic release, the physical representation of emotional anger, trauma, pain that is let out through this process. It is the tangible benchmarks that exercise allows us to set. It is somatic synchronized movement, it is optic flow. Over time, exercise, regular exercise, consistent exercise is one of the, if not best things other than like not drinking and getting a good night sleep you can do for your brain. That hippocampal volume statistic, you could literally, even into old age, reverse aging by one to two years. And that's probably more,
但总结一下，再次总结这一集，运动感觉良好有很多原因。不仅仅是内啡肽。我们知道还有内源性大麻素。还有疼痛系统。还有躯体释放，通过这个过程释放出的情感愤怒、创伤、痛苦的身体表现。这是运动允许我们设定的有形基准。这是躯体同步运动，这是视流。随着时间的推移，运动，规律的运动，持续的运动是除了不喝酒和睡个好觉之外，你能为大脑做的最好的事情之一。那个海马体体积的统计数据，你甚至可以在老年时将衰老逆转一到两年。而且那可能更多，
going to be greater than more you do it. Is it better than an antidepressant? No. is it as good as an antidepressant? Probably not either. But it is a very important method for managing well-being. It is never going to be a replacement because it just, it doesn't work that way. It's just not how exercise and the neurotransmitters and the chemicals it releases operate in the same way as, you know, a biological explanation for depression or anxiety or mental health operates. As for the role of dancing, yeah, pretty cool. One of the most important exercises, not just emotionally and physically, but also socially. So as to whether, like, going to the
你做得越多，效果可能就越好。它比抗抑郁药好吗？不。它和抗抑郁药一样好吗？可能也不是。但它是管理幸福感的一种非常重要的方法。它永远不会成为替代品，因为它就是，它不是那样工作的。这只是运动以及它释放的神经递质和化学物质与你所知道的抑郁症、焦虑症或心理健康的生物学解释运作方式不同。至于跳舞的作用，是的，很酷。不仅在情感和身体上，而且在社交上也是最重要的运动之一。所以至于，比如，去
club is a form of exercise, I think that one's up to the debate. But in terms of the emotional and social impacts, I think it totally counts. Also important to remember when exercise can become toxic and can become dangerous. There is a difference between repetition and doing exercise because you love it and compulsion and doing exercise because it's a coping tool. Remember, like, that will just, I think having that relationship to exercise will just further integrate some pretty shameful beliefs about your body and your worth and how worth and self-esteem is tied to looks and tied to your abilities. So that is something you're dealing with. I will definitely leave some links down below. I feel like I actually am hearing
俱乐部是一种运动形式，我认为这有待商榷。但在情感和社会影响方面，我认为它完全算数。还要记住运动何时会变得有毒并变得危险。重复和因为你喜欢而做运动，与强迫和因为它是应对工具而做运动之间是有区别的。记住，就像，那只会，我认为拥有那种与运动的关系只会进一步整合一些关于你的身体和你的价值，以及价值和自尊如何与外表和能力联系在一起的相当可耻的信念。所以如果你正在处理这个问题。我肯定会留下一些链接在下面。我觉得我实际上听到的
about this so much more. Exercise addiction. Exercise is self-punishment. I think it's something a lot more people have experience with. Then you may think. Then you definitely may think. But it's definitely something we can change. And if you've had negative experiences with exercise in the past, whether that's been because, I don't know, you were bullied over it, it was a painful experience for you. It was a boring experience for you, just like getting back out there and doing a little bit, finding something you love, trying out as many random-ass, like, classes as you can is like the best thing you can do. With all that in mind, that is me done for the day. Thank you for listening this far. If you made it this far, leave a little comment down below on Spotify.
关于这个的次数多多了。运动成瘾。运动是自我惩罚。我认为这是更多人有经验的事情。比你可能认为的要多。比你绝对可能认为的要多。但这绝对是我们能改变的事情。如果你过去有负面的运动经历，无论是，我不知道，你因为这个被欺负，这对你来说是一次痛苦的经历。这对你来说是一次无聊的经历，就像重新开始做一点，找到你喜欢的东西，尝试尽可能多地尝试随机的课程是你所能做的最好的事情。考虑到所有这些，我今天就到这里了。感谢你听到这里。如果你听到了这里，在Spotify下面留下一个小评论。
What is your favorite, perhaps most ridiculous exercise class? I already gave you guys mine. So if you guys are in London and you see an advertisement for a Pilates class in a sauna, know that I'm probably there. And you should definitely come and join me because it will kill you. I will say one of my friends did pass out in the class the other day. And I felt incredibly terrible for bringing her in. And actually the instructors did not give a single hoot. So maybe it would be best to avoid unless you really like to suffer through your exercise,
你最喜欢，也许是最荒谬的运动课程是什么？我已经告诉你们我的了。所以如果你们在伦敦，看到桑拿普拉提课的广告，知道我可能就在那里。而且你绝对应该来加入我，因为它会杀了你。我会说我的一位朋友前几天在课上昏倒了。我为带她去感到非常糟糕。而且实际上教练们一点也不在乎。所以也许最好避免，除非你真的喜欢在运动中受苦，
which sometimes honestly I do enjoy it. So I know I give it shit, but sometimes it's fun to like really see how far you can push yourself. Thank you as always to our researcher Libby Colbert for her assistance and her great research skills and her help with this episode. Make sure that if you are listening, you give an episode on Netflix a try. You go and watch us over there just so you can say that you've done it. Make sure you're following us on Instagram as well so you know when new episodes come out and you get the summaries and you get to see when we're doing events near you. If you want to come and meet other listeners of the psychology of your 20s, if you want to see what we're up to, that is where you can find out all about that. We also have a substack.
这有时老实说我确实很享受。所以我知道我吐槽它，但有时看到你能把自己推到多远确实很有趣。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员利比·科尔伯特，感谢她的协助、她出色的研究技能以及她对这一集的帮助。确保如果你在收听，尝试一下Netflix上的一集。你去那里看我们，这样你就可以说你做到了。确保你也关注我们的Instagram，这样你就知道新剧集什么时候出来，你得到总结，你就能看到我们什么时候在你附近做活动。如果你想来见见《心理学你的20多岁》的其他听众，如果你想看看我们在做什么，那就是你可以找到所有相关信息的地方。我们还有一个Substack。
If that is, if you prefer reading over listening or over watching, I'll leave everything in the description. But again, thank you for listening to this episode. I hope it enlightened you. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships.
如果那是，如果你更喜欢阅读而不是听或看，我会把所有东西都放在描述中。但再次感谢你收听这一集。我希望它启发了你。但直到下次，注意安全，善良，对自己温柔。我们很快就会再谈。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学，在我们这个奇怪的现代世界里。让自己经历一些磨难。
And you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“TWO%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很大。我是萨姆·杰。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选一年，拆解发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
嘿，你们好吗？你正在收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在任何地方都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改了测试一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I bowed. will be his last target.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着本季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我鞠躬了。将成为他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
他不会逍遥法外的。他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。听听闺蜜们怎么说。相信我，宝贝。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是真人。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。